you're on the Tweety aren't you not
really no I tried to do it and then I I
get angry at it don't do it for a while
and then do it yeah oh no wait that's
masturbation but yeah it's the same
are you Harry further down like are you
are you here like do you have a hairy
back
are you practicing icebreakers on me
yeah yeah
she was amazing and and she was very
funny because she wanted actually me to
forget about focusing on my accents so
it would oh
laughs
[ __ ] you can come here any night of the
week darling I'm telling you
yeah don't yeah you say it again I'm all
about
can you say it focusing focusing that is
the way no I say it legally you say it
illegally I'm hanging in there no I mean
it's uh it's really well what are you
doing what are you doing
I do
just like that you'd use that use that
machine
[Applause]
yeah are you the kind of M character in
the film who gives them the secret
weapons yeah I suppose I am there's a
bit of love interest going in there um
there is there is a moment actually
um in the film where um I I cop a feel
of his man boob
you may want to translate that for the
American audience
means uh I suppose it means you put your
hand on his gentleman's upstairs breast
Peck area yes his pectoral muscles yes I
I gently stroke who's the gentleman was
whose man boob you fell uh Chris Evans
who plays Captain America I don't think
he I don't think he has man boobs though
he's got firms well chestly areas they
were absolutely enormous though I mean
um
you know coming from you that's a hell
of a thing to say
hi
what superhero is in this movie I'd
never heard of it's called The Black
Widow and this is true the Black Widow
has no superpowers and I'm thinking
is this character even in the movie do
we have a picture of the black widow ah
I think I just answered my own question
man
Scarlett Johansson she has super powers
or breasts
[Laughter]
where are you just leave the money on
the podium
I don't take the heaviest food well I
don't know that Coconut's really a fruit
is it coconut fruit I think a coconut it
is a fruit I thought it was a nut it's a
fruit and a weapon no what and also it
can be a bra
you cut it in half you make a fortune
get in the smaller ladies in Belfast
they uh
foreign
there's a giant camera and there's you
know our whole crew is sitting around us
and stuff like that and they're like
okay so just looking directly into the
camera which is a security camera and
just
just sex it up just sex it up because
I'm trying to get this right here every
night we're getting the camera
that's all right that's what I know I
kind of look a little bit kind of crazy
I understand but but just what you do is
you go like this you could must up your
hair and then play with your lips
sorry Alex and then try to look like you
can't no you can't remember what you
were thinking I I forgot or not
I'm too sexy to remember things
you do all that you go to the dance
clubs and go there the people you don't
know
I mean I don't make that noise yeah yeah
I quite like to see I'm having trouble
keeping my eyes in one place Jennifer
why why is that they keep falling
laughs
after all this time I haven't seen you
for all this time and I'm not looking at
you at all I haven't seen you for ages
hey what's up oh yeah that's good I
think you're hearing your TVs that'll
really make it okay yeah no it is you
wear a hat on this show I've noticed you
wear a hat I do wear a hat on the show
yeah which is a shame because you've got
such a lovely head
it's such a big deal it's funny I I I
thought like this hat represents this
character like she has an attitude and
when you have a hat on as a woman it's
an attitude and so you know it makes you
feel like you have an attitude do you
know what I mean do you feel like you
have an attitude no it looks like I've
got a giant head
no it's nice it looks good no but it's
I'm surprised that you choose to wear a
hat because you're famous for your head
I am
okay
I can't believe Hollywood thinks your
head is fantastic
don't listen to this man oh I'm just
saying she wears a hat because you've
got great hand
so you're not wearing a bra
I love this
really well that's good we're having a
good time already no we are I I'm having
an excellent time although I'm wearing a
bra because but I'm older than you yeah
that's what happens with age I I love
you I've had two children I have had two
children oh they start to you need a
little more help I think mine were doing
that before the kids came along really
why are you rubbing in my chair like
this
is that is is that a bone villain thing
you'd be a good bone villain actually I
think this is you know you so I'm
subliminally maybe doing what I whoa
this might be a
oh no he does need a bra good job let me
Flex let me Flex
see men you cannot trust them
do you hear that men are going to be
obsolete in a few years yeah yeah
they're making synthetic sperm so we
don't even need you anymore
you might not but there's a couple up
there
I think they're gonna fight you on this
you know
synthetic sperm yes neatness yes an
orderly life what other let's debate
this what else you got
make a case for men
we're awesome
15 months left I don't know actually I
think with the CBS executive I don't
know if 15 months is the way it's going
to go that's going on maybe a little
less we might be a little a little less
is it just me is it just me Craig or
does the CBS sensor look a little bit
like a stripper
[Applause]
the glass a buttonable shirt and you can
do nothing because that is prime time
[ __ ] I know
scary David I don't want to go I'm not
going I'm just saying I should go no I
got scared now look at I got that [ __ ]
over there
enough scares going on in my life and
then and then there's Beth right next to
it
foreign
[Music]
as a child yes I was like a prodigy
Nikita style can you do all that can you
do all that kind of hot dog
that's me go like I think I may stun my
my opponents just by them going like
what the what are you doing that uh I I
I I can't right but I can really pretend
I could pretend my ass off don't do that
pretend something else
something okay some things you should
just leave the way they are you know
what I'm saying can I just look at this
what is this it's a tattoo has everybody
seen it but me uh not everybody they all
know about it are you allowed to show it
yeah I was just so intrigued it goes It
goes all the way up there
yeah
goes down Loops down your legs look
around you just keep going I'll tell you
when you hit the right
I I'm very excited to be here
I've been wanting to come visit you for
a long time yes I wanted to hear a love
for a long time one of the things I've
been wanting to ask you is yes if you're
gonna tear the card up at the beginning
of the segment yes why even have the
card ah you asked the question that I
don't really know the answer to it I
think what happens it's a kind of an OCD
thing oh okay I like to I like to have
something to do with my hands otherwise
I might get grabby with the guess I was
yeah I was in World War II the beginning
you were an island walking around going
gonna get him
I've never even been in Ireland I'm not
from Ireland I've never been uh where
are you from I'm from Scotland what
that's better yes it's better
[ __ ] around all day long going all right
Charlie Pump It Up
[Music]
pumping your bagpipes get a day job
I'm an American no I'm not let me see
your papers I don't even know I think I
got a tattoo I gotta touch it I got a
tattoo right there don't I I tattoo
Sailors that shows like it like you've
got a lot of class don't worry about the
tattoos you don't need the tattoos
you're a big star now hide the tattoo in
the Navy when a guy had a tattoo it was
supposed to be tough you're not tough I
met you backstage you know you
you're a nice guy with a lot of class
you know and you got a Wonderful by the
way I saw you baby oh yeah yeah my
six-month-old baby just has a wonderful
baby and the kids like this
no it's adorable do you know what's
amazing though I mean I mean this with
the greatest deal of respect he looks
exactly like you right now
[Applause]